hey everyone so in the next couple
videos I'm going to be talking about a
different sort of optimization problem
something called a constrained
optimization problem and an example of
this is something where you might see
you might be asked to maximize some kind
of multi variable function and let's
just say it was the function f of X y is
equal to x squared times y but that's
not all you're asked to do you're
subject to a certain constraint where
you're only allowed values of x and y on
a certain set and I'm just going to say
the set of all values of x and y such
that x squared plus y squared equals 1
and this is something you might
recognize as the unit circle this
particular constraint that I've I've put
on here this is the unit circle so one
way that you might think about a problem
like this you know you're maximizing a
certain two variable function is to
first think of the graph of that
function that's what I have pictured
here is the graph of f of X y equals x
squared times y and now this constraint
x squared plus y squared is basically
just a subset of the xy-plane so if we
look at it head-on here and we look at
the xy-plane this circle represents all
of the points X Y such that this holds
and what I've actually drawn here isn't
isn't the circle on the XY plane but
I've projected it up on to the graph so
this is showing you basically the values
where this constraint holds and also
what they look like when graphed so a
way you can think about a problem like
this is that you're looking on this
circle this kind of projected circle
onto the graph and looking for the
highest points and you might notice kind
of here there's sort of a a peak on that
wiggly circle and over here there's
another one and then the low points
would be you know around that point and
around over here now this is good and I
think this is a nice way to sort of wrap
your head around what this problem is
asking but there's actually a better way
to visualize it in terms of finding the
actual solution and that's to look only
in the XY plane rather than trying to
graph things and just limit up
affective to the input space so what I
have here are the contour lines for f of
X y equals x squared plus y squared and
if you're unfamiliar with contour lines
or a contour map I have a video on that
you can go back and take a look it's
going to be pretty crucial for the next
couple videos to have a feel for that
but basically each one of these lines
represents a certain constant value for
F so for example one of them one of them
might represent all of the values of x
and y where f of XY is equal to you know
two right so if you looked at all the
values of x and y where this is true
you'd find yourself on one of these
lines and each line represents a
different possible value for what this
constant here actually is so what I'm
going to do here is I'm actually going
to just zoom in on one particular
contour line right so this here is
something that I'm going to vary where
I'm going to be able to change what the
constant we're setting F equal to is and
look at how the contour line changes as
a result so for example if I put it
around here ish what you're looking at
is the contour line the contour line for
f of X y equals zero point one so all of
the values on these two blue lines here
tell you what values of x and y satisfy
zero point one but on the other hand I
could also shift this guy up and maybe
I'll shift it up I'm going to set it to
where that constant is actually equal to
one so that would be kind of an
alternative I'll just kind of separate
over here that would be the line where f
of X Y is set equal to one itself and
the main thing I want to highlight here
is that at some values like zero point
one this contour line intersect with the
circle it intersects with our constraint
and let's just think about what that
means
if there's a point x and y on that
intersection there that basically gives
us a pair of numbers x and y such that
this is true that fact that f of x y
equals zero point one and also that x
squared plus y squared equals one so it
means this is something that actually
exists and is possible in fact we can
see that there's four
different pairs of numbers where that's
true where they intersect here where
they intersect over here and then the
other two kind of symmetrically on that
side but on the other hand if we look at
this other world where we shift up to
the line f of X y equals 1 this never
intersects with the constraint so what
that means is XY the pairs of numbers
that satisfy this guy are off the
constraint they're off of that circle x
squared plus y squared equals 1 so what
that tells us as we try to maximize this
function subject to this constraint is
that we can never get as high as 10.1
would be achievable and in fact you know
if we kind of go back to that and we
look at 0.1 if I upped that value and
you know changed it to the line where
instead what you're looking at is 0.2
that's also possible because it
intersects with the circle in fact you
know you could play around with it and
increase it a little bit more and if I
go to 0.3 instead and I go over here and
I say 0.3 that's also possible and what
we're basically trying to do is find the
maximum value that we can put here the
maximum value so that if we look at the
line that represents f of X y equals
that value it still intersects with the
circle and the key here the key
observation is that that maximum value
happens when these guys are tangent and
in the next video I'll start going into
the details of how we can use that
observation this notion of tangency to
solve the problem to find the actual
value of x and why it maximizes this
subject to the constraint but in the
interim I kind of want you to mole on
that and think a little bit about how
you might use that what is tangency mean
here how can you take advantage of
certain other notions that we've learned
about in multivariable calculus like
hint hint the gradient to actually solve
something like this so with that I will
see you next video